qui décide c'est ça la vraie question
que j'aille pouvoir aujourd'hui ce ne
sont pas les citoyens ça n'est pas le
parlement européen qui votent des
objections contre les ogm monsanto et
qui ne sont jamais suivies par la
commission européenne qui décide des
parcelles concernées d'être aussi les
états c'est monsanto monsanto à
influencer considérablement les
autorités sanitaires américaines
monsanto influence considérablement les
autorités sanitaires européennes ce
qu'on appelle l'efsa
ces organisations qui doivent évaluer
les risques s'appuie aujourd'hui sur les
études privées et notamment et surtout
celle de monsanto mais ça faisait la
demande
c'est le système qui veut exactement et
donc il faut changer absolument de
systèmes ans je me lance qu'il faut
radicalement aujourd'hui transformer
tout cela on est dense devant un
scandale absolument majeur c'est toute
la crédibilité aujourd'hui des
institutions européennes qui est en jeu
donc il faut des études indépendantes
qui soit financée par de la recherche
publique ça pose plein de questions ça
parce qu'on a les moyens mais attendez
oui on a déménagé ville